(pleasant orchestral music)
- [Narrator] This is the 2018
Victoria's Secret Fashion Show.
The hour-long nationally-televised event
has served as a showcase
for the brand's bras
and lingerie since 2001,
but 2018 was the fashion
show's last broadcast.
The show had suffered several
years of declining ratings
that coincided with the
drastic rise then fall
of the stock price
of Victoria's Secret
parent company, L Brands.
Here's how the lingerie
retailer, Angels and all,
rose to the top of women's fashion
and how its fall from grace
has created an uncertain
future for the company.
In 1982, L Brands owner Leslie Wexner
acquired Victoria's Secret,
a small retailer consisting of six stores
and a catalog for $1 million.
Wexner developed many
successful retail businesses
in the 1980s and '90s.
- He popularized the
specialty mall retailer,
which had tightly-focused product lines
and carefully-designed stores,
and he took those stores
and rolled them out
to malls across the country.
That model really upended
the department store model.
- [Narrator] In the mid 1990s,
Victoria's Secret's
heavily-padded Miracle Bra,
designed to create cleavage,
was vying for market share
with its competitor, the WonderBra.
- [Announcer] Only Victoria's
Secret has the Miracle Bra.
- Get a Miracle Bra.
- [Narrator] Victoria's
Secret doubled down on ads
with provocative TV commercials
and launched its first
fashion show in 1995.
- Victoria's Secret tried
to define what sexy was
and what a sexy woman should look like,
and you can really see by the ads
that they were pushing a
very specific beauty ideal.
That image was executed
by L Brands Chief Marketing
Officer Edward Razek,
who was put in charge
of casting models for the fashion show.
- [Narrator] Throughout the 2000s,
Leslie Wexner sold many
of his apparel brands
and focused more and more on
his lingerie and beauty lines.
This included launching PINK in 2004,
a Victoria's Secret spinoff for teens.
Unlike many other retailers,
Victoria's Secret continued to grow
after the 2008 recession.
The retailer opened more
stores and sales expanded,
and L Brands stock price rose until 2016.
- That's when you really
started to see trouble
for the company as consumer
tastes started to shift.
- [Narrator] Athleisure
began to dominate fashion
and growth began to slow
in Victoria's Secret's bra business.
This was driven in part by
consumers preferring bralettes,
bras with no underwire or padding.
- There was a shift in what
female consumers wanted
from their underwear and what
they were willing to pay.
Many younger women didn't
wanna pay $60 anymore
for a padded bra that
they saw on a supermodel.
Many of them preferred stuff
like more authentic marketing,
natural looks, and bras built for comfort.
- [Narrator] In 2016, Leslie
Wexner assumed direct control
of Victoria's Secret.
He eliminated swimwear,
stopped mailing out catalogs,
and doubled down on sports bras.
By 2018, L Brands share
price had fallen 50%,
erasing about $14 billion
in investor's wealth.
Victoria's Secret started
to appear out of touch
with female consumers
around the same time.
- A major stumbling block
for Victoria's Secret
was when Ed Razek told Vogue
that he didn't think transgender models
should be cast in the fashion show.
He was forced to apologize
for those remarks,
and a lot of people called for
his resignation immediately.
He actually stayed on a while after that
and eventually resigned in 2019.
Victoria's Secret's internal
culture and management
has come under scrutiny as well.
- Ed Razek, after he
left Victoria's Secret,
has faced allegations of
harassing models and employees,
and Les Wexner has come under fire
for his ties to Jeffrey Epstein,
who was his longtime money manager.
- [Narrator] Leslie Wexner
has said that he cut ties
with Epstein more than a decade ago
after Epstein was charged
with child sex trafficking.
Independent directors
on the L Brands Board
responded to the sexual
harassment allegations
in a statement that said
the company had instituted
robust anti-harassment
policies in recent years
and the company regrets any instance
where we did not achieve this objective
of a safe, welcoming,
and empowering workplace.
Razek told the New York
Times that the allegations
were, quote, "categorically untrue,
"misconstrued, or taking out of context."
- Consumers have a very particular idea
of what Victoria's Secret is.
It'll be interesting
to see whether a brand
that's married to such a
particular type of marketing
can transform itself into anything else.
(pleasant orchestral music)